i assume ben roethlisberger has a large
head because basically he is a large
human being i don't remember seeing the
forehead blotch on him he's entering now
his what 17th 18th season in the nfl he
was drafted in 2004 so that was 17 years
ago which probably makes it year 18 i
always i never i never like having to do
that math or any math for that matter
here's what cam hayward had to say about
ben roethlisberger recently on nfl
network ben still got the goods
anyone that tells you otherwise they
haven't really looked at football you
give that guy a good running game and
tell him he doesn't have to throw the
ball 50 or 60 times he's going to be
that much more dangerous and i think
we're looking forward to that it's going
to be pretty good longevity wise if he
wants to keep playing i'm not going to
doubt cam hayward because he works with
the guy he's been around him ever since
he entered the league his first round
pick back in 2011 but
in 2019 week two
elbow goes kaflui and roethlisberger's
out for the year and i remember thinking
at the time is this the beginning of the
breakdown for a guy who clearly isn't
embracing the tb12 method
i know that folks get upset when i say
that but all you have to do is look at
ben roethlisberger this isn't a master
of playability well yeah
he's not right he's a guy who's always
relied upon running around doing what he
can
playing football and then in the
offseason he told you
the training camp before the elbow went
he doesn't throw very much at all in the
off season i don't really throw that
much he's definitely not tv 12 didn't
you know right i mean just that's not
what he is
hey big ben's just that's that's the way
he's wired he's not tb 12 or aaron
rodgers or like that no he's a little
bit more of you know we've had some good
chuckles over this over the years he's
kind of just like yeah i'm gonna eat a
burger i'm gonna go home watch some
football come home the next day and i'm
gonna play some football like he just
i'm not he's not going home and studying
the playbook or doing any of that that's
just not what he does and he just does
it on natural ability i will say though
with cam hayward
i'm not going to disagree with what he
said i do think he still has the goods
too but the big thing is like what you
said
you know it's about the health and i
think that's why that approach on the
offensive side of the ball has to
has to change uh you know one thing that
jumped out to me when free agency i mean
you know i in free agency i try to go
back and watch some of the the players
in free agency and just re like all
right let me focus in on these guys you
watch juju smith schuster a little bit
and that's when it really jumped out to
me
when i saw a big bent early in the year
last year i went oh
you know wait wow wait this is a
different guy
this he
must have had something bothering him
towards the end of the year and not been
healthy because the way he threw the
ball moved in the pocket all of those
type of things and i can't remember
specifically
what game it was i'm blanking and i need
to pull up their schedule but there was
a point there in like week five or six
where he tweaked his knee a little bit
and you saw the the change in play
so i'm with cam hayward it's about the
team and playing a different way to
where they don't have to put ben in
these
dicey situations of getting hit or
having to throw the ball too much
and chris there was constant reporting
late last year that there were issues
with his knees not just one but both of
them right and he never was on the
injury report late in the year for his
knees and you know my only way to thread
that needle is to say
hey he he's got arthritis in some
condition that you don't get treatment
for you just deal with it there's
nothing you can do you deal with it so
he doesn't get treatment he doesn't show
up on the injury report he doesn't miss
games but he's hampered by it and i
think that's got to be a concern going
into this season if if there was
something like that that he didn't get
treatment for if they weren't hiding the
injury and they got whacked in 2019 for
not disclosing the elbow injury right
that ultimately went in week two so i
i'd like to think that they didn't go
back to that well again and not properly
disclose the nature and extent of his
knee injuries but that's a real factor
he's another year older i remember
remember i said
they got just far enough removed from
the end of the season to get themselves
all worked up in their own little echo
chamber as to what they could be this
year and they got juiced up about the
possibility of bringing him back and
everything was glass half full yeah if
we get a running back and they did and
if we can work on our running game and
they will it can be better it can be
different cam hayward is singing off of
that same sheet of music yeah he is so
of course that's it's the team's built
they you know he's been told what
they're doing cam hayward knows hey
we're bringing big ben back we're gonna
he's probably heard from the coaches
offense is gonna change their style of
play so this is what we talk about like
when you formulate a team in the off
season and you want it to like kind of
come together in the off season yeah now
you got a team that's kind of got a goal
and a purpose and now here we go the 20
20 21 steelers
are coming about they kind of know the
new plan of attack here's our team
here's our quarterback all those things
and as we discussed last year of course
they're they're way closer to the top
than the bottom and you know i think
you're spot on with i think the brady
and buccaneers and how they look at that
they probably look at it the same way
and that defense of course is buccaneers
type dominant too so why wouldn't they
be able to do the same way it's all
going to hinge on the thing we've talked
about you know i'm going to say every
other week this offseason can this damn
o line come together can mike tomlin
give this team the attitude and
toughness that you and i have discussed
so much in training camp and everything
like that to get naji harris and this
run game to be a real part of their team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports